hand circles  very nice soften  different things  exhale  now how does this music make you feel  does it make you feel angelic  bend your knees if you need to  now come forward  lower halfway to crocodile  now lower again squeeze your butt  shoulders back chest lifts to cobra  now push back to down dog  arms windmill fingertips touch back heel  lift  left leg steps in  chest to thighs  deep breath in reach high breath in hold  it plank  exhale  exhale sink  into your front leg  push that back ankle down  deep breath in  belly tight  chest thighs  and  and just let those back expenses go  and breathe  now we rise  take a deep breath in  upper body slightly rotate push  your right hip down  and square your hips to the mat  very nice  now everyone think about your head  now come to the edge of your pose as you  exhale  take your hands down  are you ready to reach a circle left  hand re-reach  now if it's too difficult  come on down again